hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're looking at one of python's
sharpest corners the plus equals
operator
python is widely regarded as one of the
most intuitive programming languages
but no matter how intuitive a
programming language is it will always
have some features which are a little
bit
subtle or confusing in python one of
those things is the plus equals operator
let's take a look in this first example
we're trying to
change one of the values of a tuple but
tuples are immutable so this is a pretty
obvious error
in this case we cannot change the value
of tuple of zero
because tuple is immutable note however
that it's the tuple that's immutable not
its elements
so in this case i have a tuple of pros
and cons
which are both lists you know pros of
subscribing and cons of subscribing
and even though the tuple is immutable
you can of course
get out the zeroth element the pros and
then add something to it
that's fine you can see if i run it
there's no errors
okay so the tuple itself is immutable
but the zeroth element of the tuple is a
list which is not immutable
so will this syntax allow me to append
another element onto that list
when i run the code i get the same
errors before telling me that i can't
assign to a tuple
let's see what happens if we catch that
error with a try accept and then print
out the list
well we can see that it definitely hit
the error block but when we print out
the list
it also appended the element
what's going on i think most people
definitely expect it to either
give an error and not append anything or
to append something with no error
so why is it doing both well sharp
corner
this is according to the documentation a
feature
not a bug it has to do with the data
model and how plus equals is supposed to
work on different data types
in order to get a slightly better
understanding let's take a look at what
plus equals actually
translates to under the hood roughly
this is what
x plus equals y means it means create a
temporary
call this function i add for in place
add
and then assign the result back to x
when the left hand side of the plus
equals is an expression which is not
just a simple variable name
then you can see that this pattern
expands out to something non-trivial
filling in x sub 0 here shows us that
this actually calls the get
item method of x and similarly
putting it back here calls the set item
method this is the reason that the list
extend
succeeds but the tuple assignment fails
this first line
happily grabs the zeroth element from
the list
and then extends it which is what the
iad method will do for a list
but when it goes to reassign the result
back to x
0 that's where the error happens the
exact same thing can happen with
something like x dot val
but instead of calling the get item and
set item it will call the get
adder and set adder so if you have an
immutable object which contains a
mutable object like a list
then you can run into the same kind of
trouble okay so that's pretty wonky
behavior
why is that a feature and not a bug well
actually even just basic addition of
integers depends on it
if i set x to be 1 and then i say x plus
equals 1
i expect x to be equal to 2 afterwards
but in python integers are immutable i
can't change a 1 into a 2.
i have to point the variable x from a 1
to a different place to a 2. you can see
this by examining the unique id
that's printed out when i run the
function initially x's id
is whatever the id is for the built-in
one but afterwards it has to be the
built-in id for whatever two is
that means that plus equals must have
changed the object that x points to
this is very different from many other
languages where users have
direct access to built-in primitive
types like integers
in python there is no division between
built-in primitive types
like integers and floats and all the
other types
all types are treated the same and
therefore must have the same rules
but it doesn't stop there it gets even
weirder look at the behavior of
a similar example by taking x to be an
empty list and then appending
one thing onto the end of it using plus
equals we can see that
this time x is pointing to the same
place before and after the plus equals
for lists which could potentially take
up a lot of memory this makes sense
if i had a long list i wouldn't want to
copy the whole list over into some
new memory location with one more
element of space on the end
or this it seems like the id is always
preserved
but as we've seen with integers that
doesn't have to be the case
that can get you into a lot of trouble
if you're not familiar with how python
works
consider this example here i'm using
a bad list which is a class that i wrote
myself i'm not going to show you the
details just yet
bad list inherits from lists and all it
does is change the add and iad methods
what this code tries to do is create an
empty list
print out the list append something
using plus equals
and then append something by passing it
to a function which calls plus
equals note here that both times i will
be calling the bad list's implementation
of plus equals
the only difference in this case is that
this plus equals is called
inside of another function we have the
following very surprising results
of course the list is empty before the
append but
after the append only the one two three
is there
what happened to the four five six we
can see that the iad method
was indeed called twice and yet
only one of them succeeded so what's
going on
well looking at the implementation of
iad it's just delegating to add
which is calling the add method of the
parent list class
so in this case it's actually making a
new list with the contents concatenated
together
that explains why this plus equals
succeeded but
this one failed here bad gets reassigned
to the
newly created list here l gets
reassigned to the newly created list
but l was just a local variable it's
exactly the same thing that would happen
if i was doing this with just integers
imagine that bad was the integer zero
and here i was doing plus equals one
a plus equals 1 would succeed here
because it's in the same scope and i'm
reassigning bad
but a plus equals 1 here is just
reassigning a local variable
that wouldn't change the outer scope
this is extra tricky because
aside from reading the source code of
every class that you use
you have no way of knowing whether plus
equals will act
this way or this way in fact the python
documentation
says that it's perfectly fine to act
this way sometimes
and act this way other times thankfully
all of the classes that i know of
pick one or the other not both but
theoretically it is possible
so if you are writing a class and you
want it to work with plus and plus
equals
make sure you do so very very carefully
i should also mention that the same
applies for any of the other augmented
assignment operations
so plus equals times equals or
equals and equals those kind of things
that's all i have on this topic i really
encourage you to download the code and
play with these examples yourself
it can be really confusing at first but
once you understand what it's actually
doing
then it simplifies dramatically and
don't worry
this actually rarely comes up in real
code so it's not as big a deal as this
video might make it seem
thanks for watching if you liked the
video please consider subscribing
and as always slap that like button an
odd number of times